- Hello and welcome to
today's CIFAR Virtual Talk,
part of our series which spotlights
how research from across the academy
from computer science,
population and public health,
economics, and anthropology amongst others
may be used as the basis
for evidence informed decision making
in the fight against COVID-19.
If you're not familiar with us
CIFAR is a Canadian-based
global research organization
that convenes extraordinary minds
to address the most important questions
facing science and humanity.
My name is Rachel Parker.
I'm senior director of research at CIFAR.
It's my distinct pleasure to introduce you
to professor Brian Dias.
Brian joined the faculty
of the Keck School of Medicine
at the University of Southern
California this fall,
having made a cross country
move from Emory University
in Atlanta with his family
in the midst of the COVID pandemic.
His research seeks to
understand how neurobiology,
physiology, and reproductive biology
are impacted by stress or trauma
and how legacies of stress or trauma
experienced by parents
impact their children.
Brian was a CIFAR Azrieli Global Scholar
and is now a member of CIFAR's program
on child and brain development.
In addition to research,
Brian has sought to demystify neuroscience
and communicate the value
of science to society
in both traditional and
nontraditional classrooms
around the world.
Including, of course, he has
taught to Tibetan Buddhist
monks at monasteries
across India since 2013.
Before we begin,
today's session will last
approximately 30 minutes.
I'll be asking Brian some questions
before opening it up to the audience.
If you do have a question,
you can use the Q and A
function to submit one.
And lastly, the session is being recorded
and will be available on
the CIFAR website next week.
Brian, thanks so much for joining.
So your research is something
that seems so very relevant
to 2020 in terms of the
lasting impacts of the pandemic
and other social unrest
that we've been
experiencing or witnessing.
What does intergenerational
trauma really mean?
How does it transmit from
one generation to the next?
- Historical events and data
collected in the aftermath
of those events suggests that
atrocities that have occurred
across history not only
affect the population
of the generation that's
directly experienced
those atrocities or
environmental catastrophes,
but also future generations.
So really quickly, one of those
examples is the Holocaust.
Some descendants of Holocaust survivors
would go on to develop PTSD and anxiety
at a higher incidence
than descendants of Holocaust survivors
who did develop PTSD in the
aftermath of the Holocaust.
Even though these descendants
may not have experienced
the Holocaust themselves.
And there have been famines
that have occurred across history,
most notably the Dutch
Hunger Winter in 1944,
that suggests to us that exposure
to nutritional insults not
only affects the population
of the generation that's
exposed that nutritional famine,
but also future generations
who are not even conceived
at the time.
So that suggests to us that
there are legacies of trauma
that start off in one generation
and then perpetuate across generations.
And our challenge is to try and
understand how that happens.
And right now we're thinking
of three potential mechanisms
by which that occurs.
So at a very basic level,
we can think about social transmission,
talking at the dinner
table about the Holocaust,
about racism, about poverty
and that gets embedded under the skin
to then allow for not only the generation
that directly experienced those
atrocities to be affected,
but also future generations.
But we're also gaining a
really important perspective
in thinking that sperm and egg
might also bear imprints of trauma
in the generation that's
directly exposed to it,
thereby allowing for embryonic development
to then be affected and future
generations to be affected.
And of course there's
also the really important
maternal fetal interface,
where if there's a stressor
while the mom is pregnant,
the placenta serves as
a mode of communication
between fetus and mom,
and the fetus then bears imprints
of that intergenerational trauma.
And so that's how we're thinking
about intergenerational trauma right now,
and some of the mechanisms
that underlie it.
- So, in thinking about trauma then,
maybe not to ask the obvious question,
but what does science tell us about COVID
and how it's turned our
world upside down this year?
- Yeah, so in the stress field
there is wealth of literature
talking about two concepts
called controllability and predictability.
And so the idea being that
our stress is predictable
or unpredictable, is
controllable or not controllable.
And so you might be saying,
"How can stress ever be
controllable and predictable"?
And so for that, I'll give you an example
where you might have children in school
and they know that
they're going to be tested
at set periods of time.
And so one can control that stress.
So by preparation, it's
a predictable stress,
because you know when that's coming on.
Unfortunately with COVID, we're
firmly in the unpredictable
and the uncontrollable realm,
and that's actually piling
on misery like no other
- So given that perspective then,
could the COVID-19 pandemic
or other experiences
that we're witnessing this year
from the perspective of an
entire generation of children,
thinking about economic strain
on the family, for example,
serve as a risk factor for the type
of intergenerational trauma
and stress that you study?
- I think before we answer that question
we should take a moment to
think about how are children
and adults affected by COVID
from a phenomenological level.
And so just some of these ideas
are with respect to infants and toddlers.
There's so much unpredictability
with daycares shutting down,
with teachers being let go,
and we know that children
need that consistency,
that predictability to be able to develop.
Then there's all this mask wearing
which is really important for us
to be able to be social beings
and gain social cues from our caregivers.
And so there's that unpredictability
that comes at infants and toddlers.
There's also then when
you talk about elementary
and middle school children
how social interactions
are a key component
of developing impulse control,
of developing a stable
social relationships.
Having those masks is not helping that.
I know it's been said that eyes
are the windows to one's soul,
but as everyone can attest to right now
having these masks and not realizing
all these facial expressions
carry so much emotion,
it's difficult then for children to learn
what appropriate versus
inappropriate information is.
There's also challenges
which we need to think about
with respect to language development.
Speaking over masks is
gonna change intonation,
is gonna change how language is perceived.
And we know that children learn language
in some way by imitating
what they're hearing.
Of course, then you talk
about high schoolers
and undergraduates and how
their lives have been upended
with college applications
and not knowing what the future holds.
And a critical period called adolescence,
where you're developing impulse control,
and you can't try all those things out,
as you're not in these
social situations again.
Then, we need to talk about parenting
and how the toll of being maybe let go,
the toll of staying in the same house
in cooped up conditions might result
in physical and emotional abuse
and how that's gonna affect children.
And then last but not least,
to talk about nutrition.
And there's been a lot of
talk about food insecurity
and there are epochs
in time, early infancy,
and then adolescents where the
brain really needs nutrition
to be able to develop in
a normative LD manner,
and children are not getting that.
Some children are not
getting that right now.
And so that creates the storm
which then could perpetuate for
several generations to come.
Now we have no idea how COVID
is going to affect not only the children
who are directly exposed to COVID,
but also future generations.
But if history suggest anything,
it suggests that it will.
And we know this because one
of the most well known studies
called the Advanced Childhood Exposures,
Childhood Experience Study
has shown that exposure
to adverse childhood experiences,
like emotional abuse, like
the separation of parents
like divorce, that will
increase the incidence
of diseases like cardiovascular disease,
diabetes in the children
as well as when they
grow onto become adults.
And then of course, there's
the data which I talked about
about intergenerational
legacies of trauma.
And I'm thinking, for
example, about the 1999
ice storm in Canada,
the famines that have
occurred across history,
all of those suggests that what happens
to one generation can
affect future generations.
And so if history is anything to go by,
COVID will leave lasting imprints
not only on the degeneration
that's directly exposed
but also future generations
- Brian, that paints a fairly
gloomy picture for society.
Is there a silver lining?
- As gloomy as that picture is,
we have to hold onto silver linings.
And thankfully science says
that there are silver linings.
The die is not cast,
These influences of
trauma on the generation
that's directly exposed to them,
but also future generations can be halted,
they can be reversed, and that's our goal
as a society to be able to do that.
So how should we be thinking
about how that occurs?
One way by which we should
be thinking about that
is the importance of
nurturing environments.
And so for that,
I'll point you to the Bucharest
Early Intervention Project
which was pioneered amongst
others by Dr. Charles Nelson
who's part of the CIFAR Child
and Brain Development Program.
And what they found studying children
who are often when the
Ceausescu regime fell in Romania
and those children, some of them were put
in really impoverished conditions
in institutionalized care,
what the Bucharest Early
Intervention Project showed
is that if you can take
some of those children
and put them in nurturing
environments with foster care,
you can reverse the derailment
of neuro development,
you could reverse the physiological
ailments that persist,
you can reverse the emotional
disorders that occur
in those children.
And so the die is not cast.
I keep coming back to that
because you can reverse those imprints
of an impoverished childhood.
So then, we need to be
thinking about that mantra,
which we keep hearing again and again
which is physical distance
does not equal social distance.
And so we need to be giving our children
these nurturing environments
where they can develop not
as normatively as possible.
And when we talk about social interaction,
technology should not be
excluded from that conversation.
As one of the co-directors of the CIFAR
and Childhood Brain Development
Program talks about,
Dr. Candice Odgers, that
technology is not all bad
as the bad rap that it gets.
It can be used for positivity.
And in this case, it is to be used
to maybe a form those social groups
that children don't have
when they're not in school.
Finally, I'll just say on this point
of nurturing environments is that pods
could serve as a really
nurturing environment.
I know they've gotten a really bad rap
because we talk about being exclusive
and perpetuating the inequities
that we find in society.
So our goal is to create those pods
as nurturing environments
but to challenge ourselves
as families to be inclusive
and include families who
might not necessarily
be part of those pods.
So that was nurturing environments
being able to reverse
all these generational legacies of trauma.
Then, there's the importance
of parental behavior and caregiving.
And for this are pointed to
the work of Michael Meaney
and Kieran O'Donnell who are, again,
members of the CIFAR Childhood
Brain Development Program
where maternal care and
parental care in general
is a big component by which children
learn safe versus unsafe environments
and learn how to buffer their emotions.
And so at a time when
there's a lot of stress
placed on parents because
of the limited resources
of their time and having
to balance homeschooling
versus other responsibilities,
it's challenging for the parents,
but the parents need
to be able to reach out
to support groups as well
to be able to aid them
in being the best parents that they can be
at a really challenging time.
And so the last thing I'll say
in answer to that question
is how do we become better parents
and teach our children to
weather the storm that is COVID
and really anything
that's thrown out them?
And for this, I'll take
a page out of things
that I've learned from
the CIFAR CBD program
but a lot from the Tibetan
Buddhist monks and nuns
that I've taught over the years
in that empathy, kindness, and compassion
need to be fostered in our communities,
and that will allow us to buffer
our generational legacies of trauma
in the generation that's directly
exposed, but also future.
Now, you might be saying, "But empathy,
kindness, and compassionate
ar extremely esoteric terms.
And how do we actually inculcate them?"
And there's a Heldy literature
on social-emotional learning,
a lot of it based in Canada,
which has been rolled out
into curriculum in schools.
And so these traits can be taught.
And in teaching those traits
both to the children, the teachers,
as well as the parents,
we can create cohesive societies
that will allow us to weather a COVID,
but also future storms
that might come our way.
- Brian, there's an audience
question that's come in
that's a perfect follow up to this point.
They're asking, "Given where in the midst
of the COVID-19 pandemic
and it doesn't seem to be
going away anytime soon,
one could that it is causing trauma
and traumatic experiences.
So what are some practical
evidence-informed steps
that we can take to protect
children from lasting damage?"
- Right.
So some of the evidence based steps side
are you need supportive relationships.
And so what those supportive relationships
for children are are their parents,
if there are parents to
give to nurture them,
or an immediate community that allows them
to not feel socially isolated
because at the end of the day
we are social beings and
for them to be stripped away
from that social fabric that
really knits them together
in their community is
extremely jarring for children.
And so to try and create
that social fabric again
in whatever shape or form.
So the pods are one of these possibilities
that allow for that aspect
to be able to be buffered.
Then there's the physical
benefits of exercise, for example,
and you have children who are
now cooped up in the house
with no outlet sometimes
for physical activity
or we know that physical activity
releases neurochemical that are important
for brain development,
releases neurochemical
that allow for empathy
and for (indistinct) of
mind-related practices
to get firmed up,
that is being able to form
relationships without us.
And so to get out as best as
possible into wide open areas
like parks that are available,
to be able to allow the kids to engage
in that physical activity.
And one might also
run into and encounter
other families there
and that would give them
that social interaction
that they crave as well.
And we really need to be looking also
into nutritional aspects
of child development
because we know that there
are these times where schools,
at least in the United States schools,
who are a big source of
food for a lot of children,
and now those have gone away,
how do we really get appropriate
nutrition to children?
And so those are some
things which we can do
to really be able to buffer
the detrimental influences
of the COVID situation.
And as I said, let's
not rule out technology.
Grandparents, parents, uncles, aunts
are just now Zoom call away.
And while that might not be the same thing
as being able to physically
interact with them,
just seeing those familiar faces,
just being able to interact with them
is going to really not only
influence brain development,
but it's also going to be
able to allow them to titrate
and collaborate their social relationships
at a time where they're not getting them.
- Thanks, Brian.
So another question that's
come in from the audience
is maybe taking a turn
back to your own research.
This person's asking
about norms in the field.
So, "Research in this
field tends to be done
in animal models, whether
it mice or primates-wise,
fruit flies, honeybees, et cetera.
How do we know that these
are relevant to humans?
How do you make bridging that gap?"
- Right, and so thank
you for that question.
In fact, a lot of my research
has been firmly rooted
in the basic science of understanding
how intergenerational legacies of stress
get inherited or socially
transmitted across generations.
And so those studies
are extremely important
because they allow us to control
for variables that can't be in controlled
in the human condition.
And so we now know that using
mice, using nonhuman primates,
using flies, using worms
that there are general
principles that might suggest
that what happens in one generation
influences that generation
but also can inform
how the future generations
are going to process
their own environments.
And so we know that at this point.
What we don't know in the human condition
is how much of that is
inherited by the sperm and egg.
How much of that is actually
the maternal fetal interface
when that is actually in play,
and how much of that
is social transmission?
Those are incredibly
difficult to rule out.
Studying all of this,
I am mechanistically driven
to understand how this occurs,
but from a phenomenological level
if we don't understand this
from a human perspective
the fact that it occurs is unquestioned.
How it occurs is what
we're thinking about.
And so if the idea I keep the motivation
in front of me to beat, to reverse,
or to halt these legacies of trauma,
and at this point,
that is the central question
that we wanna answer.
And the answer to that, I
think, will be independent
of whether it was social transmission,
whether it was inherited
via sperm and egg,
or whether it was through
the maternal fetal interface.
And so I keep that as our motivation
and our ambition
and I see no conflict in
wanting to understand mechanism
but also wanting to intervene.
And that's one of the
reasons why I just moved
to the USC Keck School of Medicine
and Children's Hospital, Los Angeles,
because I would like to bridge my work
in the animal systems that I study
with human-relevant experiences
to be able to not only
understand mechanism
but also intervention
because as mechanistic driven as I am,
I also understand that
intervention is equally important
and those are things that we're
trying to really understand
at this point.
- I love this next
question that's come in.
Knowing what you do about this
important area of research
and all that is 2020,
how has your own approach to parenting
either changed or been affected?
Have you noticed any differences?
- So the first thing,
I have noticed differences
but again, I'll go back to my time
with the Tibetan Buddhist monks and nuns.
And so I don't identify as religious,
but I never wanna divorce the
scientist from the science.
And so this is something
where I've imbibed
the mindfulness aspect,
being present in the moment
aspect of my experience
with the Tibetan Buddhist monks and nuns.
And what I mean by that
is I try and give myself
grace every single day
to not have all the answers.
Some days are gonna be better than others
but I'm also looking to appreciate
again, the silver linings
because it allows me to spend time
with my son and daughter every single day
that I normally would not
have when we were just going
from soccer practice
to karate, to music, and
going on that roller coaster.
And so it's afforded me the
opportunity to take a step back
and really connect with
what I think I have lost,
which is important,
which is the familial
ties that we all have.
And so just giving myself grace
a lot of being patient with my spouse
and trying to figure out work schedules
to allow for both of our
professional careers to flourish
at this challenging time.
And also to be able to
talk to our children
about the fact that these
are challenging times,
we all have to work together
and use this as an opportunity,
even though they don't
have that social fabric
that I'm talking about to
be able to inculcate in them
some element of impulse control,
some element of realizing that
we're all in this together,
and that the only way we're
going to come out of this
is if all of us work as a single unit.
Some days are better than
others, I will admit.
But at the same time
it's about giving myself grace
that I've come to appreciate
that that's really important.
- So this will probably
be our last question.
We're just about out of time,
but going in a slightly
different direction.
Can you talk a little bit
about how cross cultural differences
might factor into,
and repercussions of
intergenerational trauma?
This person essentially asking
they imagined that that different cultures
either adapt to or experience
or allow the experience
of trauma to impact an
individual in different ways.
And so is there a body of work
that's taking into account
across cultural differences?
- Thank you for that
really important question.
And being an immigrant in
the United States myself,
it's something that I think about a lot
as I navigate my own space.
And so I grew up in India,
which is a culture
and you can't generalize India
because there's no one India,
but if I were to even do that
it would be one that has a deterministic,
it puts a lot of emphasis on destiny.
And the flip side of that is having agency
to be able to change one's fate in life.
And so I find those two
to be at two ends of the spectrum,
to be able to say that
whatever's in my fate
or whatever is I'm
destined for, will happen.
And you can think about how a
culture might think about that
from an intergenerational
legacy of trauma perspective
versus yes, there was trauma
in one's ancestral environment
but I have the agency to change that.
And so that's something which one
really has to take into account.
And the only way one
takes that into account
is by sitting down at tables
with people who have
those different viewpoints
and trying to come to some consensus,
and there might not always be consensus,
but at least realizing that
these two opposite ends
of the spectrum allows one
to be able to be empathetic
to the other side, other point of view.
But the science is firmly only
on the side of having agency,
and that agency does not only
have to come from oneself.
It could come from the community.
It could come from the social workers
that are pioneers in the work
that is done to reverse
intergenerational legacies of trauma.
But there is an agency in our communities
in our individuals to be able
to change and halt legacies
of stress from perpetuating
across generations.
- One last question.
(laughing)
We do have time.
This person wants to know,
and apologies in advance
if this is maybe getting a
little bit too technical, folks,
but what is the mechanism
by which the egg and
sperm may be affected?
So in other words, how do these
traumas in the environment
actually affect our genes?
- So within all of us,
there are molecules called
readers, writers, and erasers,
and what these readers,
writers, and erasers are doing
is they're laying down the
equivalent of punctuations,
like full stops or comma
or highlights on our books
of life, which is our DNA.
And so you can think of
the environmental event
whatever environmental event that is,
that environmental event
is then putting down
the equivalent of punctuations,
DNA methylation being one of them,
RNA modifications being another,
histone modifications being
yet another punctuation.
And what these punctuations
do is then they allow
for genes, our DNA to
either be read or not.
They allow for them at book of life
either to be read at that space
where there's a punctuation
or an edit versus not.
And so what we think is happening
is that there's a confluence,
a combination, of how DNA methylation,
RNA modifications, and histone
are found in sperm and egg
that then biases embryonic development
to roll down one side of a
hill to give, for example,
a mental health state that is detrimental
or to roll down another side of the hill
where that mental state does not manifest.
And so we want to think
about the DNA methylation,
the histone modifications,
and the RNA found in sperm
and egg as punctuations
that allows the book of
life to be read differently.
And as orchestrators of gene expression
that then allow for the
multicellular UNI to form
in rolling down a hill,
on one side, mental health
states being prevalent
on one side, the resilience
to those mental health
states from developing.
- Brian, thank you so much
for taking the time to
answer our questions.
It's been a pleasure
to hear about your work
in the context of COVID.
And I just wanted to again thank you
and wish you the best of luck at USC
as you get settled in Los Angeles.
- Thank you.
Wishing everyone good health.